en union soviétique toujours il ya deux
ans jour pour jour le nuage radioactif
qui s'était échappé de la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl qui avait
explosé le 26 avril à mme rivet sur la
france pour la première fois depuis
cette époque des journalistes qui
l'entourent français en l'occurrence et
ont été autorisés à se rendre sur place
pour y constater que contrairement à ce
qu'on avait pu laisser entendre
et bien la vie était loin de reprendre
normalement comme il est convenu de dire
à tchernobyl
non seulement mais aussi dans ses
environs patrick est au bout de cette
route qu'a pu emprunter hier un petit
groupe de journalistes français
la centrale de tchernobyl les autorités
nucléaires soviétiques avaient décidé de
jouer la transparence de l'information
ici dans la salle de contrôle numéro
deux c'est sur fond de musique apaisante
que les techniciens travaillent les
journalistes ont pu constater que les
réacteurs étaient de nouveau à plein
régime et que la centrale produisait
déjà entend d'électricité qu'avant
l'accident
il est toutefois pratiquement certain
que ces réacteurs n'ont pas été équipés
des systèmes de sécurité prévus après
l'accident
de son côté l'ingénieur en chef a
reconnu que le sarcophage de béton qui
emprisonne le réacteur accidenté n'est
pas étanche l'air qui circule à
l'intérieur pour le refroidir et rejetés
dans l'atmosphère dans un cercle de 30
km de rayon les immeubles sont toujours
inhabitée et le resteront en deux ans
l'air va pousser à travers le bitume et
la piste d'autos tamponneuses à rouiller
depuis que l'eau passe à travers la
toiture détruite en plein centre ville
une serre a été construite pour étudier
l'effet à long terme des radiations sur
les plans maigre consolation pour les
soviétiques ils sont devenus les
meilleurs spécialistes mondiaux de la
décontamination
une expérience dont il se serait passé
un peu plus loin à 28 km de là au
village de patch ichi quelques vieux se
sont réinstallés dans la maison ou leur
famille avait vécu trop âgé pour
enfanter
ces femmes ne risque plus de transmettre
des anomalies génétiques aux générations
futures
alors elles sont revenues avec l'accord
tacite des autorités malgré les
conditions précaires
malgré la présence du monstre invisible